DAVID SHIROKOFF: Hi, everyone.
So today I'd like to take
a look at linear equations,
linear first-order
differential equations.
And specifically, we're going
to look at just exactly, what
is a linear equation?
So for example, which of
these equations are linear?
And then second of
all, we're going
to take a look at superposition.
And we ask to consider
the differential equation
y dot plus y squared equals
some function q of t.
And just to demonstrate that
this equation does not satisfy
the superposition principle.
So I'll let you take a
look at this problem,
and try and work it
out for yourself.
And I'll be back in a minute.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
All right.
So we're asked to figure
out which of these equations
are linear.
So just to recap,
what does it mean
for an equation to be linear?
What does it mean for
a first-order equation
to be linear?
Well, it means that we can
write it in the general form,
so if it's a
function of x, dy/dx
plus some general function of x.
And this could be anything.
But the point is that
it's multiplied just by y.
And then it can equal
some arbitrary function
q of x on the right-hand side.
So every first-order
linear equation
can be rewritten in this form.
So let's tackle part A. All
right, y dot plus k*y equals--
or y dot equals k*y.
We can just rewrite it as
y dot equals negative k*y.
Note that just some constant
k is a function of time.
It's a constant
function of time,
but it can just be thought
of as a function of time.
Same with the
right-hand side, it's 0.
And so this equation
has the same form
as our general first-order
linear equation.
So this is a linear equation.
Let's take a look at
question 2, part 2.
We have y dot plus y squared t.
I'll bring the y to
the left-hand side.
If we do that, we get this.
And just by comparing this to
our generic first-order linear
ODE, we note that
it's not of this form.
So specifically, this is
the bad term in question.
We see that it's
y squared times t.
Notice how we're not allowed
to have any term that's y
squared in our first-order
linear equation.
Now I will say this
just as an aside.
This equation's also known
as a Bernoulli equation.
And as an aside, if you were
to make a substitution u equals
1 over y, and rewrote this
equation in terms of u
as the independent
variable, you'd
find out that this equation
would be linear in terms of u.
But as it's written now in
terms of y, it's not linear.
So this is a kind of
an interesting point.
That sometimes we can get
lucky and do a nonlinear
transformation and
convert a nonlinear
equation into a linear one.
So for part 3 we have y prime
plus cos(x)*y equals x cubed.
So again, we see that
this is a linear equation
because we can identify
p of x with cosine x, q
of x with x cubed.
So this equation has the
general form of a linear ODE.
For part 4, well if we take
a look at it right away,
y dot divided by y is
equal to t squared.
It doesn't appear to be linear.
But of course, we can
multiply through by y
and rewrite things.
And of course, this
equation is equivalent to y
dot minus t squared y equals 0.
Which again, is
linear because p of t
can be identified with
negative t squared and q of t
can be identified with 0.
And then lastly,
for part 5, we have
x squared y y prime
plus 4x equals x cubed.
And again, if we were to try
to write it in the general form
of a linear ODE, which we have
here, it would look like...
4x divided by x squared y minus
x cubed divided by x squared
y equals 0.
And because there's a y
on the denominator here,
this equation doesn't
have the general form
of a first-order
linear equation.
Now again, I note that if you
were to make a substitution,
u equal to y squared,
that substitution
would make this equation linear.
So this concludes part a.
So for part b, we're given
a differential equation
y dot plus y squared
is equal to q of t.
And we want to show that
this equation doesn't satisfy
the superposition principle.
Now, you might note that
this equation is not linear.
And second of all, we know
that linear equations satisfy
the superposition principle.
So we need to exploit the fact
that it's a nonlinear equation
to make it fail the
superposition principle.
And just as an example,
what we can do is I
can just pick a couple
right-hand sides
q as examples of this ODE.
So we can imagine we
have a solution y_1 which
solves the ODE y_1
dot plus y_1 squared
equals-- I'm just going to
say 1 on the right-hand side.
And I can also take
another function
y_2, which say satisfies this
differential equation, say t.
So all I've done
is I've just picked
one q_1 on the right-hand
side and another function q_2.
And I imagined that I
have a solution y_1 which
satisfies this differential
equation and y_2 which
satisfies this
differential equation.
So what does the
superposition principle say?
Well, superposition
says that if y_1
solves this equation and
y_2 solves this equation,
then the function y equals
y_1 plus y_2 must solve
the equation y dot
plus y squared equals
the sum of the right-hand
side, 1 plus t.
So if we try and
substitute in y_1 plus y_2
into this equation, we're going
to come to a contradiction.
So let's do that now.
So we take d by dt
of y_1 plus y_2,
and I'm going to add it to
y_1 plus y_2 quantity squared.
And now what I can do is
I can just simplify this.
So I get y_1 dot plus y_2 dot.
And I can expand
out this square.
So I get y_1 squared plus
y_2 squared plus 2y_1*y_2.
And now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to combine the term
y_1 with y_1 squared.
And by construction, y_1 dot
plus y_1 squared is equal to 1,
because I assumed that it
satisfied this differential
equation.
And then in addition by
construction, y_2 dot plus y_2
squared satisfies
the right-hand side
of the second equation with t.
So I get 1 plus t, but I'm
left over with this other piece
2y_1*y_2.
So in general, if I
take a function which
solves this differential
equation and another function
which solves this
differential equation,
and I add them
together, and plug it
into the left-hand side of
this differential equation,
I get something which is 1
plus t plus some other stuff.
And if it did satisfy the
principle of superposition,
it must equal 1 plus t.
So we arrive at a
contradiction because it
doesn't equal 1 plus t.
In fact, it fails to equal 1
plus t by this term 2y_1*y_2.
And this term comes directly
from the fact that we had
a nonlinearity in the equation.
So this is just one
illustration of the fact
that a nonlinear equation
doesn't necessarily satisfy
the superposition principle.
Whereas, every linear equation
satisfies the superposition
principle.
This is one reason we
love linear equations
and we study them extensively.
OK, so I'd just like
to conclude here.
And I'll see you next time.